Ja.
Ja, und tak.
Mein Name ist Gündüz. Ich bin in der Notaufnahme als Assistenz Ersynthetik.
Und wir gehen mit Ihnen das Anamnesi-Geschbrehführung in Ordnung für Sie.
Ja, gerne.
Bevor wir mit uns errempeln, möchten wir Ihnen ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder etwas Fragen haben, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Okay?
Okay, schön.
Darf ich Ihren Namen erfahren?
Ja, mein Name ist Steven Koch.
Können Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen buchtabieren?
Ja.
Vorname ist Steven.
Ich schreibe wie Siegfried, Theodor, Emil, V, E-N, Emil Nordpol.
Steven, Nachname ist Koch.
K, O, C-H.
C-H, okay.
Herr Koch, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin um 16, 50 Jahre alt.
Was ist der Gunagheborun?
Ich bin am 5., 10., 65 geworden.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,76 m groß.
Wie viel wiegt ihr zur Seite?
Ja, so ungefähr 80 kg.
Okay.
Herr Koch, was für Bescheid haben Sie zur Seite?
Ich habe seit 3 Monaten in meiner rechten Leiste geschmerzt.
Wir sind seit 3 Tagen schlimmer geworden.
3 Tage sind schlimmer geworden.
Aber Sie haben es seit 3 Monaten verwendet.
Ja, genau.
Sie haben die rechten Leiste geschmerzt.
Genau, meine rechten Leistenregion.
Gibt es dort etwas ungewöhnliches Knoten oder so?
Nein, nicht, dass ich höchst.
Ich habe da nichts besonders getastet.
Wie beschreiben Sie die Schmerzen?
Wenn ich hier sitze, tut mir nichts weh.
Nur wenn ich laufen möchte, gehen möchte,
tun mir die ersten 5-10 m weh.
Ich habe weniger Schmerzen.
Am Anfang spürst du dich mehr?
Mehr, wenn ich lange sitze und aufstehe,
dann tut mir weh.
Aber wenn ich 10-20 m gelaufen bin,
dann geht es wieder.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wenn Sie die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10
beschreiben müssen, wo würden Sie einschätzen?
Das heißt, dass Sie die Schmerzen auf einer Skala beenden.
Ja, ich würde schon sagen, 8.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie eine Schmerz,
die ich auf der Schmerz auf der Schmerz habe?
Nein, nicht, dass ich höchst.
Gibt es eine Schmerzprobleme?
Am Knie?
Ja, keine Probleme.
Zur Zeit nicht, Gott sei Dank.
Okay.
Spürst du dich mehr?
Wenn Sie die Schmerzen auf einer Skala beenden,
tun Sie z.B. morgens oder abends?
Ja, das ist eigentlich immer nach Belastung für das Weh.
Seit drei Tagen tut es die ganze Zeit wie egal, wie ich belaste.
Aber bis zu den drei Tagen war es meistens morgenschmerz
und abends in Ruhe auch Schmerzen.
Okay.
Manchmal.
Okay, Herr Kuhl, um Ihre Allgemeinsustand zu beurteilen,
möchte ich Ihnen noch weitere Fragen stellen.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein?
Ich fühle sich gut.
Ja, sehr gut.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Magen oder Darm?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich höre Sie, Ihre Herr Manchmal ist in der Alstung.
Ich habe mit dem Herz noch keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Lungenprobleme, Atemnot?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Vassalassun oder mit dem Urin?
Nein, auch nicht.
Hat Ihrer Gebi, hat sich Ihrer Gebi in Neste sein verändert?
10 Gewalt?
10 Gewalt? Nein.
Okay.
Leidung Sie unter relevanten Erkrankungen, Herr Kuhl?
Ich meine Bluthochdruckdiabetes.
Ja, also macht Bluthochdruckerkrankungen,
dann nenn ich ein bisschen Medikament ein.
Welche Medikamente nennst du?
Nennst du Azea-Hemma?
Wissen Sie, wie heisst das?
Azea-Hemma, 10 Milligramm.
Okay.
Abgesehen von diesen Medikamenten, nehmen Sie noch etwas ein?
Letzter Zeit bei Bedarf, im Profen.
Ich nehme mich ein, 800 Milligramm, weil ich Schmerzen habe.
Ja, ich habe Schmerzen.
Okay.
Und ich nehme noch, wie heißt das, Allopurinol ein.
100 Milligramm.
Der Hausarzt.
Ich hatte einmal früher vor zwei Jahren Gicht gehabt.
Gicht am Fall gehabt und da hat er mir das verschrieben.
Seitdem Leidung Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit fünf Jahren bestimmt oder zehn Jahren.
Wann hatten Sie Gicht am Fall, Darf ich fragen?
Das war glaube ich vor fünf Jahren.
Abgesehen von diesen Krankheiten haben Sie noch weitere Medikamenten?
Nein, nicht, dass ich rüster.
Was ist mit dem Verkauf der Operation?
Ich habe mich in meiner Jugend an Blindam geopert.
Wie war die Operation gelaufen?
Laufen war ohne Probleme gewesen.
Das war keine Komplikation, ganz normal.
Das war, was ich mich erinnern kann.
Okay.
Herr Koff, sind Sie vollständig?
Ja, was meinen Sie mit vollständig?
Ja, mein internationaler Ausweis, der ist voll.
Ich glaube, ich bin schon alles geimpft.
Haben Sie den Corona-Impfung bekommen?
Ja, ich habe die ganze Zeit dagegen gestimmt.
Aber vor drei Wochen habe ich meine zweite Impfung bekommen.
Sind Sie alle alleergegen?
Nein, ich habe alle alleergen nicht, dass ich rüster.
Vertrag Sie alle Lebensmittel gut?
So weit ich weiß, ja.
Sie haben keine Probleme?
Mit diesem Kürbis habe ich keine Probleme.
Brauchen Sie, Herr Koff?
Ja, ich habe keine Probleme.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so ein Glas Wein, abends trinke ich schon gerne.
Zum Essen oder zum Fernsehen, zum Lesen.
Als Ihre Ersten muss ich fragen, ob Sie Drogen konsumieren?
Drogen?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie Drogen beschrieben wird.
Was ist das für eine wichtige Erkrankung für Ihre Familie?
Wichtige Erkrankungen.
Mein Vater hat auch eine Bluthoftung Erkrankung.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob das für Sie wichtig ist.
Und meine Mutter hat eine Erkrankung.
Wie alt sind meine Eltern?
Meine Eltern sind 82 Jahre alt.
Und die Mutter ist 80 Jahre alt.
Wie ist Ihr Vater?
Ich habe ein Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Er nimmt zwar einen Medikament ein, aber für was ist das ein?
Was ist Ihr Beruf?
Ich bin Busfahrer.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Mit wem leben Sie?
Mit Ihrer Familie?
Mit wem leben Sie mit meiner Frau?
Mit einem?
Ja, ich habe zwei Söhne.
Der eine wohnt zu Hause.
Und der andere ist verheiratet.
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Das sind faule Säcke.
Ich habe von meiner Arbeit eine wichtige Frage gestattet.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie tun?
Ich habe zwei Söhne.
Der eine wohnt bei mir zu Hause.
Und der andere wohnt mit mir zu Hause.
Das ist schön.
Aber sind Sie ein Kind?
Nein.
Noch nicht.
Das sind faule Säcke.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie tun?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, wie geht es denn weiter?
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Was passiert jetzt mit mir vor der Frau?
Ja, Herr Koch, so erst muss ich sie körperlich unterzogen.
Nur anhand dieser Beschwerden kann ich leider nicht genaues
aber nach der Unterzuhung können wir in alle Ruhe besprechen.
Okay.
Ich habe eine Frage in der Gruppe.
Wie ist ein Unfall?
Ein Unfall? Nein, ich hatte keinen Unfall.
Also jetzt aktuell nicht.
Ich hatte vor circa zehn Jahren ein Verkehrsunfall.
Und damals hatte ich eine Prellung gehabt.
Aber jetzt aktuell habe ich keinen Unfall.
Abonnes ich hier bei der Frau nach Schweiß.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ist es ein Sport?
Sport? Nein, ich war ab und zu mal Fahrrad.
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen Arsch gewesen?
Ja, wegen der Beschwerden.
Nein, ich hatte immer Schmerzmüll genommen.
Das ging ja drei Monaten.
Aber jetzt seit drei Tagen sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt hier in der Notaufnahme.
Haben Sie unterpüfte Fieber oder Farbe verwendet?
Farbe verwendet, sie bemerkt.
Nein, also Wärme meint sie.
Fieber ist ja ganz körper.
Werben oder Rötung bemerkt, nein, habe ich nicht.
Keine weitere Fragen.
Aber wie sind die nächsten Zeit auch noch zu genomen?
Akut, zu genomen, nein, Herr Dr. Bündnis.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstereoknose, wenn ich fragen darf?
Ich habe eine Verdachtstereoknose, die an einem liestigen Angaben
deuten, am meisten aufkorkst, Artrose hin.
Sollen wir die Vorstellung machen?
Okay.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt, hätten Sie Zeit für mich, ich möchte Ihnen
einen Patienten vorstellen.
Okay, ja, bitte gerne.
Herr Steven Koch ist ein Patient, der 56 Jahre alt,
ein Meter, 670 gross, 10,8 Kilogramm, schweigt.
Der Patient hat sich wegen Zeitdreif, Monat 5,
aber Zeitdreif taggen, sunnenen,
Kokosalji Bay uns vorgestellt.
Laut dem Patienten, Zündlich Mersen,
haben Sie sich an den Angriff begonnen, aber Sie haben
die Zeit für die Verstehung geblieben.
Der Patient sagt, am Anfang bei Bewegung
verschmürfen Sie die Schmerzen,
aber dann zinken Sie die Schmerzen.
Nehmen Sie die Schmerzen ab?
Nehmen Sie die Schmerzen ab.
Außerden berechnet er morgens die Schmerzen,
von morgens die Schmerzen.
Beim Züsten würde ich die Schmerzen linden.
Und auerden bei Belastung würde ich die Schmerzen
beenden.
Die vegetative Anamnese war unaufhellig.
Buay der For Erkran, Kugeln,
fand uns die eine arterielle Hipertonie.
An dem er seit fünf Jahren leide
die Medikamente an der Anamnese,
er gab das Raseha Hema,
als Jugendalter,
eine Appendektome bekannt.
Er sei verständlich geimpft,
er habe zweite Corona-Infug aufbekommen.
Bei ihm sei keine Allergen und
die Verträglichkeit bekannte.
Er ist nicht rauch, er trinkt abends ein Glas Wein,
Drogen konsumvurdun fernayt.
Sein Vater leide an arterielle Hipertonie,
der zwei Jahre alt ist.
Seine Mutter leide an Diabetes melluturs,
die erst sechs Jahre alt ist.
Er hat eine Bruder,
er nehme ein Medikament,
aber der Name ist nicht bekannt.
Er ist Busfahrer, verheiratet,
habe zwei Söhne.
Okay.
Eine andere Frage.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob der Patient eine Parise hat?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Durch Blutungsstörung?
Ja, ich habe nicht gebracht.
Okay.
An welche Erkrankungen haben Sie ans Erste gedacht?
In Ersterlinie, in Feltmia,
in Kokosartrose,
aber außerdem ein
Pferd,
als Sie als Drucknuss denken.
Waren Infektionen?
Nein, vom Becken kann auch Schmerzen ausstrahlen.
Z.B. ISG, Ilyosacralgelenksyndrom,
ISG-Syndrom, kann auch einen Leistenschmerz machen.
Und auch einen Leistenschmerz machen.
Gefäßerkrankungen,
aber die Pferd-PfK,
aber der Patient sagt,
am Anfang bei Becken,
ist es nicht so, dass es nicht so ist.
Es ist gut.
Deswegen haben Sie dies ausgeschlossen.
Ja, es ist gut.
Wie gehen Sie voran, um Ihre Verdachsdiagnose,
die erste Diagnose zu erhärten?
Was würden Sie vorschlagen?
Zur weiteren Abklärung müssen wir
so erst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann, MRT kommt infrage oder CT.
Als Erstes kommt Ihnen,
wenn Sie sagen, es ist eine Kokosartrose,
dann kommen Sie gleich mit großen Geschwossen.
Was ist das einfachste, günstigste?
Rundgenaufnahme,
zwei Ebenen Rundgenaufnahme
in diesem Bereich.
Wie würden Sie,
wenn Sie eine schriftliche Anordnung schreiben würden,
an den Kollegen?
Wir würden Sie das Rundgen anmelden.
Wir haben das gesagt, ich finde das noch mal genau.
Aber zuerst muss ich den Namen dem Partikeln anmelden.
Es geht nicht um Ausfüllen von diesen Dingen,
sondern es geht um Anordnung.
Hüftgelenk,
beidseitig,
Röntgen,
Handgelenk,
rechts in zwei Ebenen.
Die Anforderung wäre,
Röntgen, Hüftgelenk,
rechts in zwei Ebenen.
Ich möchte ein System erklären,
egal wo das ist.
Röntgen, Handgelenk,
rechts in zwei Ebenen,
Röntgen, rechts in zwei Ebenen,
Röntgen, Sprunggelenk in zwei Ebenen,
Röntgen, Hüftgelenk in zwei Ebenen.
Man könnte theoretisch eine Beckenübersichtaufnahme machen.
Und zweite Ebene, also eine Aksialle Ebene der Hüfte,
aber zuerst für eine Hüfte reicht aus,
wenn man strahlen schon und ist.
Wir wollen ja nicht vergleichen,
wie die Hüfte zu sein aussieht,
sondern wir wollen gucken, ob deine Arthose ist oder nicht.
Als zweite Diagnose,
was man erwähnt,
die Diagnose an Diagnostik, würden Sie was machen?
Wir müssen Bulut abnehmen,
um die Enzyntin-Parameter zu überprüfen.
Wenn wir
einen CT
machen,
müssen wir auch ...
Was würden Sie erst sagen?
Ein MRT oder ein CT? Welches Aussage kräftiger?
MRT ist weichteil
GWB BESA,
deswegen
für mich ist MRT BESA.
Wenn es künftig ist,
dann CT vielleicht,
aber Koksarthose können mit MRT BESA beurteilen.
Also beim Röntgen
reicht aus, um eine Koksarthose zu sehen.
Aber manchmal sagt es nicht sehr kräftig,
wenn es eine beginnende Arthose ist
oder wenn es eine beginnende Hüffkopfneckrose ist
und so was, so eine beginnende Hüffkopfneckrose,
sehen Sie nicht in einem CT.
Beim CT würde man machen,
wenn eine Deformation des Hüffgelenkens ist,
damit man vor einer Operation besser planen kann.
Aber ansonsten für die Diagnostik
reicht es alleine, wenn man ein Röntgen macht.
Wenn es nicht aussagekräftig ist,
kann man noch zusätzlich ein MRT machen.
Das ist zwar eine weichteil Aufnahme,
aber mit MRT sehen wir z.B. auch Dämen im Knochen,
als Zeichen einer aktivierten Arthose.
Man sieht mehr Informationen.
Aber normalerweise reicht Röntgen alleine aus.
Aber in früheren Stadien
werden die Klinik, also die Untersuchung,
ergibt, dass der Schmerzen hat, z.B. eine Hüftrotationsschmerz.
Und in Röntgen sehe ich nichts Besonderes.
Dann kann man ein MRT machen, z.B.
Man würde auch z.B. ein Tumor erkennen,
den man in Röntgen nicht erkennt.
Hatte ich schon mal gehabt, einer Dame,
die hatte vor 15 Jahren eine Marmarkatzelung gehabt.
Seitdem alles okay.
Die kam dann wegen Hüftrotationsschmerzen
und habe im Röntgen gerömpft.
Im Beginn der Arthose aber nicht besonders.
Aber die Untersuchung war auffällig.
Die konnte man nicht richtig rotieren.
Und haben MRT gemacht
und hat man gesehen, dass eine metastasierte Marmarkatzelung war.
Das habe man im Röntgen nicht gesehen.
Manchmal sieht man nicht alles im Röntgen.
Z.B. bei beginnenden Arthosen
oder bei unklaren Sachen, wo man sagt,
da muss irgendwas mit der Hüfte sein.
Ich möchte noch ein MRT machen, um genauer zu sehen.
Manchmal gibt es Stressfrakturen
oder bei Ostepolitikern z.B.
Wie gehen Sie vor?
Sie haben jetzt eine Coxarthose festgestellt.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Die Therapie, die Sie haben,
die Therapie richtet sich nach der Schwergrat
der Coxarthose.
Im schlimmsten Fall kommt ein Tep in Frage.
Genau.
Tep ausgesprochen, das ist richtig.
Man sagt immer Hüfttep.
Was ist aber Tep ausgesprochen, ausgeschrieben?
Total endoprotese.
Genau.
Was empfehlen Sie sich?
Wir empfehlen den Patienten
Gewicht, Reduzierung
und
Muskelverkraft
Physiotherapie.
Ja.
Das ist ein Problem.
Der hat ja Schmerzen.
Er nimmt
2 Ibuprofen ein.
Aber wir wissen nicht, ob das regelmäßig gegeben wurde.
Man kann eine Woche regelmäßig Ibuprofen
3-mal am Tag.
Eine Woche durchgehend einnehmen lassen.
Wegen antiflamaturischen Wirkungen.
Wir kommen.
Wenn Patient
Einnahme von Ibuprofen
besiegt,
was empfehlen wir?
Manche Tablette, wie Handelsfragen zum Beispiel.
Eine andere Möglichkeit
Schmerz-Tablet.
Es ist ja 2 Sachen.
Das 1 ist,
wenn man orthopädisch gesehen ein Schmerz da ist,
ist eigentlich zu 90%
immer eine Information, eine Entzündung dort.
Okay.
Nummer 1, soll das Ziel sein, die Entzündung zu therapieren.
Da gibt es 2 Gruppen.
Die eine Gruppe heißt, nicht steuere Deile Antirheumatika.
Aber die andere Gruppe heißt,
es ist eine Gruppe, die eine Art.
Man sollte entweder 1 von den Beintherapien,
das ist das 1, plus Schmerztherapie.
Wenn natürlich jemand
Kontrahentikation hat,
wie Nieren und Sofizienz,
oder Probleme hat mit
Morphine oder irgendwas,
Kontrahentikation, dafür Hitte,
dann kann man halt nicht sehr viel machen.
Da kann man nur Analgesie, Analgeltikatherapie machen.
Von Nauvalgin bis Morphine.
Eigentlich kann man immer bei orthopädischen Patienten sagen,
wenn es möglich ist,
die Profin dreimal am Tag für 3-5 Tage oder eine Woche einnehmen.
Durchgehende einnehmen.
Viele 80% der Patienten nehmen das nur bei Bedarf
als Schmerzmitlein.
Die Wirkung von den Profen ist 6-8 Stunden.
Das müsste er dreimal am Tag verteilen
oder viermal am Tag, dreimal am Tag verteilen.
Und das auch noch 3-5 Tage.
Wenn das nicht reicht, reicht, kann man noch andere Therapien machen.
Zum Beispiel, hatte ich erwähnt, Kortison,
Gabel zum Beispiel.
Physiotherapie ist wichtig, genau.
Man kann auch Joao Leronsäuren Infiltration
ins Gelenk infiltrieren.
Röntgen, Reizfisch.
Also gibt es mehr Möglichkeiten, wie man eine Enzytomtherapie hat.
Ah, PRP?
Ja, ich höre PRP durch.
Man macht nicht sehr viele durch.
Also ist regional bedingt bekannt.
In Münchner Raum ist sehr bekannt.
Frankfurter Raum ist nicht so bekannt.
Es ist unterschiedlich.
Es ist nicht Nummer 1, weil es viele Sachen sind nicht von der
Versicherung bezahlt, wird nicht von der Versicherung bezahlt.
Auch Joao Leronsäuren nicht, aber Joao Leronsäuren
ist bei den Orthopänen auch hier in Deutschland sehr,
sehr bekannt.
Also da gibt es verschiedene Arten von Joao Leronsäuren, die man geben kann.
Joao Leronsäuren ist bekannt, aber PRP ist nicht so bekannt.
Ich habe noch einen Punkt, der alles ist.
Joao Leronsäuren ist auch PRP.
Ich würde sagen, beides hat seine Vorteile.
Die Studie hat ergeben, man hat eine Vergleichstudie gemacht
und dort hat gezeigt, dass PRP ein wenig besser
abgeschnitten hat.
Also jetzt auch nicht bombastisch, aber nur leicht ein bisschen mehr.
Also ich, deswegen behandle ich auch meine Patienten
mit PRP, aber nicht jeder möchte das haben.
Warum?
Ja, das ist so ja.
Genau, kostet ein bisschen mehr.
Aber ich kann ja nur empfehlen anbieten.
Die Patienten nehmen das an, aber nicht an.
Bei mir nehmen wir es eher an, aber als in der Regel
in einem Kassenpatient, also ich habe eine Privatpraxis
und daher nehmen wir es eher an als woanders.
Bei mir kommen wir...
Wird Joao Leronsäuren vom Krankenkassabersalt?
Wie?
Wird Joao Leronsäuren...
Nein, wird nicht bezahlt.
Okay.
Es ist egal, ob sie zu einer Privatpraxis gehen
oder zu einem Arzt, der auch einen Kassen-Sitz hat,
Joao Leronsäuren soll es jetzt nicht übernommen.
Okay.
Das ist aber billiger als PRP.
Kommt darauf an, es gibt Joao Leronsäuren.
Die sind teurer im Markt.
Es gibt verschiedene Marken.
Das gibt Joao Leronsäuren, die sind natürlich günstiger.
PRP ist auch, weil es nicht ein Standardprodukt ist,
kann jeder seine Preise so ein bisschen bestimmen.
Wer sagt, der kostet so viel oder so viel.
Okay.
Ist unterschiedlich.
Was ich noch hinzufügen würde bei Ihnen ist,
bei der Anamnese, also bei der speziellen Anamnese,
direkt wo Sie fragen, seit wann es wehtut und so weiter,
da würde ich immer als Gedankenstütze...
Da gibt es einen Satz in der Orthopädie oder Unfallschirurdi.
Es steht meistens immer drinnen in einem Ambulanzbrief.
Die Periverde durch Blutung, Motorik, Sensibilität,
durch Blutung kann man an einem mäßig fragen,
also untersucht und technisch, ja, kann man fühlen.
Aber es geht hier um Anamnese.
Da kann man ja fragen, zum Beispiel,
ist der rechte Bein kälter als der linke Bein?
Gibt es einen Temperaturumstell, zum Beispiel.
Bei Motorik haben Sie Kraftverlust.
Das ist ein sehr guter Bein.
Aber man muss manchmal ein bisschen genauer hören.
Das sind zwei Sachen.
Paräse, wenn manche sagen, ich habe Kraftverlust,
weil er Schmerzen hat.
Wenn es durch Schmerzen bedingte Kraftverlust hat,
ist das keine Paräse.
Man muss das halt raushören.
Und DMS ist Sensibilität.
Sensibilität haben Sie Gefühlstörungen, Kribbeln.
Kribbeln, wie weit es geht, wenn ich an die Kribbeln.
Ich habe eine Bein.
Ich habe die Schmerzen in eine bestimmte Region gezogen.
Z.B. hätte ich gesagt, der Leiste in meinen Knie.
Z.B.
Zieg die Schmerzen.
Das ist ein Standard,
bevor Sie die anderen Anamese anfangen.
Mit anderen Erkrankungen,
das man sortiert, aber am Anfang direkt fragt.
Sie haben direkt gedacht,
ab und nach Schmerzen, das ist Koksatuse.
Ja, sehr unrechtlich. Das meinst du.
Aber damit die Zeit auch voll ist bei der Prüfung,
das sind die Strukturen bei der automatischen Sache,
die sie denken, kann man fast immer sagen,
DMS-Intakt, auch wenn es Lumboschalgie ist,
Cervicobrachalgie ist, kann man auch sagen,
wie es an dem Arm oder wie es an den Bein ist.
Danke.
Wollte ich noch ein bisschen. Bitte schön.
Hat jemand noch eine Frage oder Sie in der Gruppe?
Von welchem Land, woher Sie hier kommen?
NRW.
NRW, okay. Detail ist nicht so,
sondern es ist ein Hayer.
Okay, gut, schön.
Wenn Sie keine Fragen haben,